perú declara emergencia ambiental por 90
días en la costa afectada por el derrame
de petróleo que según el ministerio del
medio ambiente ha contaminado casi 174
millones de metros cuadrados de mar ha
puesto en riesgo la vida marina y la
salud de los residentes locales este
grave problema que se ha presentado
ecológico está afectando la salud de las
personas y de los animales también que
acá esté viven no en las personas hemos
tenido esta gente con dolores de cabeza
síntomas como irritación ocular garras
pero en efecto el ministro de salud ha
ordenado un despliegue a lo largo de
todo el litoral para atender a los
enfermos y proporcionar las medidas
preventivas y la información necesaria a
los vecinos afectados entretanto los
residentes que dependen económicamente
de las actividades marinas sufren las
consecuencias
realmente es una pérdida de
de días laborables como ustedes cuenten
yo cuento con 12 personas de trabajo y
afectó bastante la playa son cuatro días
sin trabajo y realmente la economía y
encima los afectó la pandemia y ahora
viene el petróleo
y no sé qué hacer el oleaje negro se
produjo el 15 de enero cuando un buque
petrolero de la empresa repsol
descargaba su crudo en uno de los
terminales multiboyas en la costa de
lima repsol que había atribuido la
catástrofe a la erupción de un volcán
submarino en la remota isla de tonga
dice estar comprometida en remediar los
efectos del derrame mientras que
naciones unidas ha anunciado que un
equipo de expertos llegará en los
próximos días para evaluar el impacto
socioambiental y hacer recomendaciones
al gobierno peruano sobre cómo manejar
la situación